[Music]
Christian
like inside
[Music]
little Christian
what
[Music]
down
hello hello
hi so happy to see you all glad you're
here with us um my name is Rachel my
pronouns are she and her um so excited
that you're with us it's baptism Sunday
as you can tell um so we're so glad you
could be with us on this special day um
first thing is um we have this new
little bucket over here this little
black bucket um that was created so if
you are anxious about being in a church
setting if you're a part of the
disability Community or you just feel a
little fidgety today there's some tools
in there that you can use um some
fidgets things like that um that are
available to you to use throughout the
service we just ask that you'll return
them at the end so others can use it um
next uh uh save the date for January
26th at 6 PM after church for a class
introducing you to one of the most
misunderstood letters in the
lgbtqi A+ Community uh the T for our
trans siblings um as many of you know
trans folks are heavily politically
attacked right now now so this is an
opportunity to understand more and learn
more about how we can love and support
those in the trans Community um to be
clear this isn't a class so much for
Trans folks just for the rest of us to
know and understand more um and you can
sign up by scanning the QR code behind
me um February 2nd we're going to have
our first Sunday meal we're going to
have a potluck in the fellowship hall
immediately following service um and
we're sharing our favorite soup recipes
um so you can scan and the QR code to
sign up to bring some
food so looking at these candles um they
are a sign of the presence of Christ
Among Us fully Divine and fully
human now we exit the kingdom of noise
hurry and
productivity now we enter the kingdom of
Silence Stillness and simplicity a
Sacred Space a place for prayer worship
and adoration a place to behold Christ
revelation of God heartbeat of
creation allow The unforced rhythms of
Grace to find you to mend your heart may
we all come
home good evening if you guys want to go
ahead and stand with us Gary's going to
get started um he's going to start us up
on this first song so you guys can
follow along with him but we just want
to invite you to participate in this
service um fully so be free to engage
with worship as it feels right for you
if that's lifting your hands if that's
singing out if that's standing and
absorbing these words or sitting and
reflecting on them we want this worship
space together to be something that's
meaningful for us as a community to
enter into as one not as worship leaders
up on stage and then you guys taking it
in down there on the floor but all
together as one we sing out these words
or we believe them in our hearts because
we believe that Jesus is good that he's
for us and he's with us each one of us
so we just invite y'all into this time
together go ahead
[Music]
Gary Darkness I roll over my
bones the sorrow comes to steal the joy
I when Brokenness and pain is all I
know oh I won't be
Shen oh I won't be
Shen my fear doesn't stand the chance
when I stand in your love of my fear
doesn't stand a chance when I stand In
Your Love of my fear doesn't stand a
chance when I stand in your
[Music]
love she no longer has a place to
hide and I am not caped to the life
I'm not afraid to leave my P
behind oh I won't be
Shen oh I won't be
Shen my fear doesn't stand a chance when
I stand in your love my fear doesn't
stand a chance when I stand in your love
my fear doesn't stand a chance when I s
in your
[Music]
love there's power that can break off
every
chain there's power that can empty out
of
grave there's resurrection power that
can take there power in your name power
in your
name there's power that can break off
every
chain there's power that can empty out
of
grave there's resurrection power that
can save there power in your name
there's power in
your my fear doesn't stand a chance when
I stand in your love my
fear chance I stand in your love my fear
doesn't stand a chance when I stand in
your
[Music]
love my fear doesn't stand a chance when
I stand in your love my fear doesn't
stand a chance when I stand in your
my fear doesn't stand a chance when I
stand In Your Love
[Music]
all right
kiddos they're aimed and
ready Brock and Kelly thank you guys so
much for taking care of our kids tonight
and those that are back in the
nursery you guys have a great
time and as they exit we are going to
transition into the pr of the people so
if you guys would follow along on the
screens we are going to read aloud the
parts in red together and then we'll
pause in the middle for you to offer up
anything that you're carrying into this
space and you can just speak that aloud
and we just want to hold that before
Jesus
together Jesus for this city of saxi
Texas and for every city and community
and all who live in them we pray to you
for the Good Earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it we pray to you for the old
and the sick for the Widow and orphan
for the injured and suffering we pray to
you for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you for the
vulnerable the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality
race or other perceived difference we
pray to you for those experiencing loss
loneliness and disconnection and for
those struggling with mental and
emotional health we pray to you Lord we
know that you love us and that you hear
us so we lift these names and situations
up to
you John
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your
presence amen
let's sing We have
suffered we have suffered all kinds of
grief tasted the bitter cup of
defeat out of
the something sweet of fa more PR
and
gold we have been tested by so
many burn In the Heat of what our hope
requires find us here singing in a
foolish CH our faith more pre than gold
our faith our faith more precious than
gold sing though we
don't though we don't see you we love
you when we don't feel you we still
sing we've got a reason to trust
you Jesus in
[Music]
everything everything Lord
there is a secret we can
only walking through places we don't
want to
go cuz in the dark we learn a song of
hope our faith more preious than
gold our faith more precious than gold
though we don't see you we love
you when we don't feel you we still
see we've got a reason to trust
you Jesus in
Everything
Jesus Jesus in everything sing tears
tears on the
altar from all we've lost
following you no matter what it
cost maybe a
whisper May a roar this is the sound of
those who love you Lord this is the
sound of those who love you Lord tears
tears on the
altar from all we
lost following you no matter what it
cost
maybe a
whisper maybe a ro this is the sound of
those who love you this is the sound
this is the sound of those who love you
Lord though we don't see you we love
you when we don't feel you we still
see cuz we've got a reason to trust
[Music]
Jesus in
Everything
Jesus Jesus in Everything
Jesus Jesus in
everything tear on the
altar from all we
lost following you no matter what it
cost maybe a
whisper maybe a ro
this is the sound of love this is the
sound is the sound of those who love you
Lord this is the sound of those who love
you Lord this is the sound of those who
love you Lord
[Music]
in Ephesians 3 it says but whatever was
to my profit I now consider loss for the
sake of
Christ what is more I consider
everything a loss compared to the
surpassing greatness of knowing him
Jesus Christ my lord for whose sake I
have lost all things I consider them r
that I may gain Christ and be found in
[Music]
him here is where I lay it down every
bird in every Crown this is my
surrender this is my
surrender here is where I lay it down
every every Crown this is my
[Music]
surrender and I will make room for
you to do whatever you want to
to do whatever you want
to and I will make room for
you to do whatever you want
to to do whatever you want to
[Music]
here is where I lay it down every bird
every Crown this is my
[Music]
surrender this is my
surrender here is where I lay it down
every Li and every doubt this is my
[Music]
surrender and I will make room for
you to do whatever you want
to to do whatever you want
to and I will make room for you
do whatever you want
to to do whatever you want
[Music]
to so shake up the ground of all my
tradition break down the wall
of all My Religion your way is
better your way is
better shake up the ground of all my
tradition Break Down The Walls of all My
Religion your way is
better yes your way is
better shake up the ground of all my
tradition break Down the Walls All My
Religion your way is
better your way is
better shake up the ground of all my
tradition Break Down The Walls for my
religion your way is
[Music]
better your way is
better and I will make
room for you
[Music]
to do whatever you want
to to do whatever you want
to I will make room for
[Music]
you to do whatever you want
to to do whatever you want
[Music]
bre here is where I I lay it down you
are all I'm chasing now this is my
surrender this is my
[Music]
surrender here is where I lay it down
you are all I'm chasing now this is my
surrender
[Music]
God whatever we have
lost whatever it is that we've laid
down or given
up to follow
you to become the person that you
made to be found in Jesus
Jesus God all of that we consider loss
but for the cause of knowing
Christ and we
believe that you have come to
redeem to make
new to
[Music]
restore guys you don't leave your
children
empty-handed you don't leave them to beg
bread you are a good
God you meet our
needs you call us by
[Music]
name you claim us as your
own God would we be found in you
[Music]
Jesus thank you for calling us by
name for seeing
us would we know your voice would we
listen for it God would we follow it
[Music]
it's in your name that we pray all these
things
tonight
[Music]
amen thank you guys for worshiping
together with us if you would turn to
the people around you and say hello
we'll continue with our service
oh Grace and
peace it is uh it's good to be with you
all so so good my name is Brett and I'm
the pastor here pronounce he him and uh
yeah it's a joy joy to to welcome you
and uh into this this space and a new
year and uh also want to welcome those
join us online glad yall are with us to
the wonders of the internet and uh
especially anyone who is new whether
this is your first time or just your
first time in a while uh we're really
really glad that you're you're here with
us so uh tonight is uh you know you've
come on a special night because as is
fairly evident by the large horse trough
uh in front of us it is baptism Sunday
you can tell we're evangelicals we H got
we're a post evangelicals I guess many
of us claim now um but yeah we're kind
of come from that tradition so we're
we're obviously dunkers and
uh and um yeah so it is it's a really
special a special evening and um for
those kind of unfamiliar with like
baptism maybe and some of its meanings
and and all that uh there's it's kind of
one of those things a little bit like
art where it's a it's a rich you know
symbol so it's it's hard like pin it
down like oh okay so this is what it
means this one thing it's it's kind of
it's a very rich picture so um one of
the images is kind of one of like death
and Resurrection right the the person's
kind of laid down in the waters
symbolizing like the death of Christ and
then you're raised to New Life and like
New Creation so it's kind of that image
um but also just the kind of nature you
know of water is uh used to kind of um
you know purify and cleanse so it's also
uh kind of a picture of like for the
Forgiveness of sins the the the
cleansing of the of the person and um
and that's actually where my message is
going to kind of focus tonight so the uh
the title of my sermon is Against the
Grain and we have two um scriptures
tonight the first is from the book of
Acts chap 2:
38-39 which reads Peter replied reent
and be baptized every one of you in the
name of Jesus Christ for the Forgiveness
of your sins
and you will receive the gift of the
Holy
Spirit the second is a short Parable
that Jesus tells from Luke chapter 18
verses
9-14 to some who were confident of their
own righteousness and look down on
everyone else Jesus told this Parable
two men went up to the temple to pray
one a Pharisee and the other a tax
collector the Pharisees stood by himself
and prayed oh God I thank you that I'm
not like other people robbers evildoers
adulterers or even like this tax
collector I fast twice a week and I give
a tenth of all that I get but the tax
collector who at that time that would
have been um a pretty despised kind of
position because was often involved in
like extorting people for more that's
kind of how you Maj your living was
getting extra from people and such um so
the tax collector though stood at a
distance he would not even look up to
heaven but instead beat his breast and
said oh God have mercy on me a
sinner then Jesus continues I tell you
that this man rather than the other went
home Justified before God for all those
who exalt themselves will be humbled and
those who humble themselves will be
exalted you know it's often um I think
it's like the most sort of
obvious
questions
that almost never get asked I think
because we kind of um assume you know we
just assume the answer and it's not
until someone asks it and then we're
kind of like forced to you know
articulate it or give an answer that
we're like we realize kind of how I
don't know maybe inadequate or full of
holes our response actually is you know
our heads it was all worked out but then
said were like I don't even know what
I'm talking about and I had one of these
um one of these moments a few months
back where a sweet couple here from the
table um said it was sort of like one of
those moments like hey after the service
we need to talk to you you know it's
kind of okay and they're like don't
worry nothing bad nothing bad you know
which is also that's helpful by the way
if you need talk to me just it's helpful
you say nothing bad nothing bad
otherwise don't give me a warning just
go just out with it you know um so
anyway so we they catch me after the
service you know kind of jumped to the
side whatever and they're like okay so
we have a question I was like all right
they said what is
sin and I was
like now it this this wasn't because
well I can already hear kind of my um my
friends call them friends my friends
online my more maybe theologically kind
of conservative friends who they're
already laughing they could hear they
are catching this sermon on Facebook
they're like ah typical Protestant
liberal Pastor like oh sin I don't know
what sin would never talk about that you
know wouldn't want to offend any want or
something they're like see this what
we're talking about you but it's not so
much like I I didn't H like had no
response you know I was like I have no
idea um it was more like my mind was
kind of flooded with all sorts of
responses and answers and you know
angles at it but then I was like I don't
know but it I wasn't sure if any of my
potential responses were like really
getting at the heart of the matter it is
it's one of those questions like a
little bit of like sort of like what's
baptism you know that's sort of like
well there's a lot of angles on that but
to get kind of to the roots of it is a
you know it's sort of a different thing
and uh like so here's for example some
of the things that immediately came to
mind uh sin is doing wrong you know sin
is missing the mark which is sort of a a
image of like archery right you have
your life and there's kind of an aim and
a goal and a the right thing and then
you you know you you miss you miss it
sometimes uh sin is failing to do the
good we know we should do this is kind
of like there's sins of commission right
where you do a wrong thing and there's
like Omission like I just didn't do
anything but that itself was wrong you
know uh sin is breaking God's law that
last one that's definitely like a very
biblical type Answer 1 John 3:4 puts it
this way everyone who sins breaks the
law in fact sin is
lawlessness right so now by law uh we
hear that we think like the laws the
United States of America or the state of
Texas if you're if you sped on the way
here because you're running late you
know that's a it's it's not so much like
those kinds of laws it's thinking more
of like books in the Bible like um
Exodus Leviticus there's a number of
books that have kind of Many religious
laws and rules and such and I mean the
preeminent example of course would be
something like the Ten
Commandments you know those kind of
outlining like don't don't
lie you know don't
steal don't cheat people don't you know
it's just kind of going through right or
in in the positive kind of like you know
love God and honor your father and
mother and you know these these sorts of
rules and laws kind of you know naming
it but uh you know but even saying that
like kind okay well that's the
dictionary definition there you go first
John 34 sin is breaking God's law you
know again it can feel a little bit like
yeah but but like but why that why is
that a sined like that's specific why is
that one of the laws and why is that not
and you know it kind of it's a little it
can feel a little bit like a maybe a
parent who's you know like well telling
their kid like you know what's right is
what I tell you you know and then the
kid and when they're three they're like
okay you know but when they're well
maybe not three maybe even by then
they're already questioning but you know
at some point they're kind of like
whatever you say you know by 13 say
they're just like well well but
why you know well well that's not enough
for me just cuz I said you know and and
you it can feel a little bit like that
so anyway I've been thinking about this
kind of question like ever since they
asked me like months back and I came
across a quote from a theologian named
Ron Williams uh that really it really
resonated with me and he kind of unpacks
this so he he puts it this way he says
sin isn't some sort of high drama
satanic Defiance shaking your fist at
the lightning it it isn't even exciting
naughtiness you can tell he's British I
think that's a British thing naughty
exciting
naughtiness um he says this it's just
the condition of being seriously wrong
about
reality and living Against the Grain I
love that imagery of Against the Grain
if you've ever um like done any
carpentry or anything you know how
dangerous it is to run your hand against
the grain of something that has not been
sanded yet right it's just like oh like
you are bound to you can go with the
grain all day you go against the grain
like you're going to end up with not one
not two like a half dozen instantly just
you know it's you will feel the pain
right and and that's that's kind of the
image like and maybe not always
immediately you know but just kind of
reflect on your life when we start going
down that road of wrongdoing like
eventually like we know even if by the
way even if we have everyone else around
us a little bit fooled you know like oh
fine but on the
inside like we we know this is not
working like in other words to
acknowledge that I am a sinner is not to
believe that I'm trash or I'm Unworthy
of Love or something it it's simply to
admit that how I am
living is not working I think of uh for
example the first step in alcoholic
synonymous which says to admit that I am
powerless over alcohol and that my life
has become
unmanageable it's that last part my life
has become unmanageable how do you know
believe me you know you know what I mean
like and that's kind of how sin is like
you you know when your life is getting
manageable and of course not everyone
struggles with specifically alcohol or
some form of substance abuse but but s
just has this way of making our life
unmanageable unhospitable un unlivable
you just reach a point where you say
like I can't keep living my life against
the grain of how God created the world
to work this leads us to what the Bible
calls
repentance this moment where we say
look I'm done living Against the Grain I
am exhausted by it I'm so tired of it
like I cannot do this
anymore and and there's a turning that
happens this of course is um this is not
a one-time thing often in the Christian
Life there is in certain Traditions do
really emphasize sort of that first
repentance or something turning to Jesus
you know but but really the idea is uh
it's the first of many you know that
there's it's this kind of ongoing
process I think of a a kind of image
it's a little bit like you've ever been
um on like traveling up a mountain now
most roads now are kind of switched back
but just imagine like a road that goes
like circles a mountain and you're kind
of you're like slowly making your way up
right the image there would be you're
traveling sort of up towards God towards
Christ towards sort of like peace in
wholeness and a life lived well but
along the way you're hitting these um
just imagine you hit like certain
roadblocks these these points where you
realize like I I'm I'm living Against
the Grain and you've got to kind of
bring your life like back into alignment
so that you can keep going now at times
it may feel like I'm going in circles
I'm getting nowhere but that's not
actually the case right you're actually
you're it's not a circle but it's a it's
a spiral upwards
and the roadblocks aren't like the same
ones but you're there's kind of deeper
Dimensions you're um you're breaking
through new depths new opportunities for
awareness repentance and surrender and
those I would call that kind of the if I
had to give this sort of a formula I'd
say that's the formula in our life we
need awareness repentance and surrender
or if you're like looking for a way to
remember this just think ours
a
RS we're all a little bit of an ARS
right and this is why we need awareness
repentance I know some of you were
wondering like did he mean to say what
he just said like yeah no for sure
um this is um I think in many ways if we
think back onto Luke 18 like that's kind
of the the picture um that we see there
from the Gospel of Luke where we have
these two very different types of people
right first you have this this Pharisee
who of course in the story is not really
named The Sinner in fact he's very busy
pointing out the other people who are
The Sinner you know it's that oh thank
God I'm not you know so and so and such
and that person that that type of person
you know and yet interestingly enough in
the
story who's the one that's kind of stuck
on the mountain who's the one not moving
forward anymore
it's actually that
person and then vice versa right the one
in the story who's named like The Sinner
the tax
collector it turns out that they're
actually in this much better like heart
posture even though there is like
they're kind of a broken person in a way
but it's like broken in a good way like
in a in an honest acknowledgement of
where they've been living Against the
Grain and and so what is that that tax
colure has that
awareness that sense of repentance God
forgive me I want to go a new way and
then surrender right teach me your path
show me your ways Lord I want to live in
alignment with who you really are you
see true religion is an inner process of
awareness of repentance of surrender to
God that then does does what it
initiates us into living with the grain
of the
universe and again the beautiful thing
is that we just keep spiraling higher
and higher like the process is never
ending which at first I get sounds like
depressing like no I want to be done you
know I want to like have my moment I'm
okay I'm aware now I see it I'm moving
forward and then I'm good you know for
like three years uh after first it is
it's difficult because there's a lot of
roblo but it's like as as we
spiral upwards what what happens there
is a greater and a greater and a greater
Freedom it's a freedom it's freedom to
live with with awareness I heard uh oh I
think it was Carl Young said something
like um this the subconscious or the
unconscious will rule your life and you
will call it
fate in essence what you are not aware
of is
already ruining your
life does that make sense so that's why
it sounds like no I don't want to see
like even in the story The Pharisee oh
thank God I'm not like that can you see
the utter lack of awareness he think
thinks he's doing awesome he thinks he's
the best he's the the best believer the
be the most faithful of the Lord you
know and where everyone around him is
like oh it's
gross lack of awareness so this is the
beautiful thing is when we grow into
that awareness right it seems hard it
seems oh I don't want to see it no no
trust me trust me better that you see it
awareness and then we have to do
something right it's not necessarily
enough just be aware but awareness that
leads us then to repentance okay Lord
forgive me and to others if we need need
be you know forgive me and then
surrender I'm following your ways um in
own life I'll close with the story this
is um you know I could name a hundred
areas where this happens and continues
to happen but um more recently I I think
I I've been seeing this kind of growth
and awareness and repentance and
surrender in the in my life um really
here as as pastor and church planter I
uh I gather with a few other pastors
every few months for a a reading club
little little book reading club and we
of course you get to discuss whatever
reading but there's also a chance to
kind of you know ask like hey how are
you you know in those kinds of
conversations and so they were asking me
like how how are you this is back just
before Christmas and uh I was like you
know honestly I feel like the past few
years I have not so much been learning
learning like how to
Pastor I have been
unlearning how to Pastor does that make
sense like it's it's what I'm realizing
is I came to this experience um with
like so much so many like expectations
sort of ideas even sort of Demands on
like myself and others and what God's
going to do and this and that how it's
going to look and like and I realized
like well in essence so much
me in it and I just I'm seeing with with
new eyes like oh
no not good like that that's all that
has to be let go of and so on the one
hand it's
painful
um but on the other hand it's beautiful
because as I step into that as I real
like for example just to give it a more
concrete thing like um the demands on
people there's such a
freedom in just giving sort of
responsibility for people back to God
instead of like that's very tempting for
a pastor of course to you know kind of
take on me you know and it's and then
that gets weird you know what I mean and
manipulative and and I'm realizing like
no no no no no even though it's scary
hands off kind of like a parent who
you're to some degree of course Hands-On
but the older they get you know it's
like you can't be there like
micromanaging you're 21 one-year old's
life you know what I
mean and and I realized like no no no no
no just freedom freedom give people
freedom and it's hard but it's also so
beautiful and um I don't know I hope I
hope people can start to maybe sense
that you know um so kind of that's
that's so that's been me you know like
God I Surrender I I I'm aware of it I
repent and I Surrender and I'm I'm
giving really this whole Community Lord
like back just back to you and um I
think in many ways this is like what the
Christian life is all about you know
finding those areas where we need
greater awareness having the humility to
recognize oh man I'm a sinner again not
in the sense of I'm unworthy I'm trash
I'm nothing not not that but just I'm
human just human I so human and I need
God I need the Holy Spirit I need Christ
to fill me and lead me forward so that's
the the
process and uh
today as we uh in just a moment
baptize the one the only Jessica
Rodriguez I'm so excited um as we do
that it's really you know you can think
of it it's a moment for her right to say
um to realize hey I'm on this path and I
want to move forward with Christ um but
it's also a moment for us
all
um
to yeah to kind of take a certain
inventory in our own life our own heart
and mind to say like you know how are we
how are we doing um how are we growing
on the path so
um I'm realizing that just is going to
get her swimsuit on and I was ready to
baptize like right now so I think this
is what we're going to what we're going
to do is um we're going to go ahead and
participate in communion we'll do that
first and then um we'll have our our
baptism that sound good
so on
uh on the night that Jesus was betrayed
he had one final meal with his disciples
and at that meal he um took a loaf of
bread and he broke it and he said Take
and Eat This is my body it's broken for
you and then he held up a cup of wine
and he said this is my blood and it's
shed for you whenever you eat this bread
whenever you drink this cup remember me
and so for 2,000 years now Christians
have come to the table to take in the
body the blood of Jesus and and so
tonight we get to we get to participate
in that and so as you come to the table
um you know maybe you're in a place
where there's some areas in your life
where you're needing some awareness
right you're you've become aware and now
there's there's those next steps of
repentance and surrender that God's
inviting you into I encourage you to
yeah to participate um or to kind of
bring that with you as you come as you
come forward so this is the table not
the church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you
who've tried to follow and you who feel
like you've just failed it's okay come
because it's the Lord Jesus himself who
invites you and it's his will that those
who want to meet him should meet him
here come to the table
[Music]
for e
will you all pray with
me Lord
Jesus for those of us who have been
baptized we remember again our calling
our identity and our
hope and we celebrate with Jessica as
she plunges beneath these holy Waters
may she be forgiven and walk a life
utterly surrendered to you every day of
her life in the name of the Father the
Son and the Holy Spirit
amen so our Lord Jesus Christ has told
us that to enter the kingdom of heaven
we must be born again of water and the
spirit and he's given us baptism as a
sign and a seal of this new birth here
we are Washed by the Holy Spirit and
made clean here we are clothed with
Christ dying to sin that we may live his
resurrection life here as children of
God we have a new dignity and the Lord
invites us to fullness of
life so as Jessica Rodriguez comes
forward for will you all give her a big
round of
[Applause]
applause oh my
gosh all right so I want to start by um
just having you share with everyone a
little bit of why you'd like to be
baptized
today I I wrote something on my
journal so good evening everyone I stand
before you today with a heart full of
gratitude and joy as I take this
important step in my spiritual journey
baptism is profound is a profound and
sacred moment and I am deeply honored to
share it with all of you first and
foremost I want to
thank God for his unwavering love and
grace it is through his guidance and
mercy that I have found my way to this
moment I am humbled by his presence in
my life and the countless blessings he
has bestowed upon me I also want to
express my heartfelt appreciation to my
family my son my
sister your support encouragement and
love Have Been instrumental in my
journey thank you for standing by me and
sharing in this joyous
occasion today I am baptized I am I am
reminded of the words of Romans 6:4 we
were therefore buried with him through
baptism into death in order that just as
Christ we were raised from the
dead through the glory of the father we
too
may live a new life this verse resonates
with me as it signifies the beginning of
a new chapter in my life a chapter
filled with hope faith and a renew
renewed commitment sorry I'm really
nervous to live accordingly to God's
will I'm excited to Embark in this
journey of faith knowing that I am not
alone I want to thank each and every one
of you for being here today I'm grateful
for to share this moment with you and
may God bless you abundantly thank
you um yeah you want to bring her towel
all right my friend you want to go ahead
and step
[Music]
in yes we warmed it up for you friend
we're not going to do that to you in
January the snowy
Waters all right if you want to go ahead
and sit
down I have a few questions before I
baptize you yes Jessica do you repent of
the sins that separate us from God in
neighbor I Repent do you turn to Christ
as Savior
I do do you submit to Christ as Lord I
submit all
right going to do one hand here hold
your nose and then with this hand you'll
hold your arm Jessica because you repent
of your sins and you've decided to turn
to Christ as Savior and toit commit to
Christ as Lord I now baptize you in the
name of the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit
[Music]
[Applause]
one thank you
yeah here's your sandals
there you
go it's a beautiful huh yeah give her
another
hand will you pray with me Lord Jesus we
pray that our new sibling in Christ
would flourish in every
way we pray that her family her places
of work her community
would be blessed for her commitment to
serve you we pray that she would become
a model of
christlikeness patient kind loving a
deep well of compassion and moral
courage and we pray that all of us who
have witnessed this day would be renewed
in our own baptismal vows to go with the
grain of your created order in the Holy
Name of Jesus Christ I pray
[Music]
amen you are
not what you have
done or what
has been done to
you you you are
something like the Rising Sun can't you
see that you
[Music]
are you might
have your father's
name or bear the
shame that's left
behind but there's new
life
flowing through your veins leave some
room to be
surprise you are
new every
morning you are
new Every Morning each day a
resurrection is waiting to break through
[Music]
you could
try just for a
start to put the
judge back on the
Shelf all the
loving kindness
in your heart have a
little for
yourself you are
new every
morning you are
new Every Morning each day of
Resurrection waiting to break
through you think hope is lost but it's
just
underground the flame might be an EMP
but the Fire won't go
out all the evidence is pointing to the
TR the daily Resurrection is still
happening to you you
are every
morning you are new
every
morning you are
new every
new Every Morning each day of
Resurrection is waiting to break
[Music]
through you are
new you are
[Music]
new thank you so much for being here
with us this evening um if you're new we
would love for you to fill out the QR
code or fill out a card on the table or
scan the QR code just so we can say
thanks for being here or answer any
questions about uh what this community
looks like things like that we can all
use more relational support and
spiritual connection and the way we do
that at the table is through meetups um
if you're not yet part of a Meetup um
you can scan that QR code um to find one
that works for
you generosity is a key aspect of a life
of adoration and worship if you call the
table your home um we invite you to scan
the QR code um to join us in giving
financially or you can visit the TBL
tx.org
okay now I'm going to send you into your
week with a benediction with a blessing
you can hold out your hands in a posture
to receive or just open your heart to
receive these
[Music]
words you are a child of
God you are a child of God
this is true on your best day and it's
true on your worst day so as you go into
your week ahead with it's yet to be
determined highs and lows and everything
in between go filled with the assurance
that you are loved you are worthy and
you are accepted just as you are and go
filled with God's Holy Spirit and the
desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come into contact with be blessed
and we'll see you next Sunday thank
you you think hope is lost but it's just
underground the flame might be
in the Fire won't go
out all the evidence is pointing to the
TRU that daily Resurrection is still
happening you you are
[Music]
new every
morning you are
new Every Morning each day of
Resurrection waiting to break you
[Music]
you are
new you are new
[Music]